et c'est un jour de la victoire à
célébrer au delà des frontières de le
refi est même plus loin encore vous
allez le voir on va parler de l'espace
trois astronautes de liesse ont envoyé
un message de félicitations aux
habitants de la terre vous propose de
les écouter tout de suite dans la gadoue
zia si vos chers amis le 9 mai 2021 nous
oleg nowitzki piotr dubrovnik et marque
d'un deuil ce matin salue donc tous les
habitants de la terre depuis la station
spatiale internationale à l'occasion du
grand jour de la victoire aux tubes il
était pas bien des bons ce jour même il
y à 60 saison la grande guerre
patriotique a pris fin cette journée est
à juste titre considéré comme l'un des
événements majeurs du xxème siècle qui a
déterminé le futur développement
pacifique de la civilisation humaine
nous nous souviendrons toujours des
grands exploits des soldats et des
travailleurs de guerre témoin nous nous
souviendrons des millions de victimes
avec l'aide des canaux grand-père et
arrière-grand-père ont pu arrêter les
forces de destruction et rétablir la
paix le droit à la vie et la liberté se
souvenir sera pour nous toujours sacré
aux leaders nationaux c'est chiant mais
c'est nous tous qui vivons et
travaillons à bord de la station
spatiale internationale sommes unis dans
un seul but poursuivre pacifiquement les
découvertes et les recherches profit de
l'humanité tout entière et css est un
brillant exemple de coopération
internationale ne sera aidé la nasse
c'est un honneur pour nous de vivre dans
ce laboratoire de recherche
international félicitons la planète
terre de tout notre coeur en ce jour de
la victoire est bien des nous vous
souhaitons à vous et à toute l'humanité
paix bonne santé bien être et bonheur